There's something though. That's real my babies. There's something though.
That's not a joke.
And it's how much I will never eat Sabra
hummus again. Why?
Because of their commercial. Now I always say this here,
there should be no bad commercials period.
There shouldn't be bad commercials. Do you know why they're 30 seconds?
Do you know why 30 seconds of content should be easy?
Even if you're trying to get a message across and you're trying to take people's
money. Okay. Kleenex or whatever the it is.
I saw.
This is all like just
the whole culture or I don't even want to use that word. The whole
Superbowl commercial.
It's just people who say they watch super bowl
just for the commercials. Are,
are the most boring people in the whole universe. All right.
Cause do you know what the commercials in the super bowl, they suck. All right.
Maybe there's two funny ones every three years, but like,
they're not that good. All right. Also, if they're that good,
they should always all be that good. Every commercial ever.
So really you're just being a Kuda thinking.
They're good because they think they have to be that good commercials are so
easy. Dude. The most famous commercials of all time that have been spanning, uh,
spanning time, spanning time. We're spanning time ever that and Buffalo, 66,
we're going to span time.
One of the greatest movies ever asked them for a photo once and he said,
I'd rather not. And I was like, Oh yeah, I forgot. You're a weirdo.
It's all good. And um,
you know, D D Superbowl commercials, they pumped so many,
so much money into it and they're just so bad. All right.
And I'm not hating, but I, you know, it's like, get it together. Be better.
They're all glossy and.
This Sabra hummus commercial just takes the cake. Okay.
First of all, the catchphrases America, how do you mus?
All right. You're trying to make a thing. You're trying to make a catch phrase.
Now this comes from your boy Kango catchphrases.
I don't try to make these catchphrases. I don't, they pop off when they pop off,
I let them speak to me. Okay.
I put out in the world, whatever I talk about. It's.
And when somebody says, yeah, I'm a baby. I say, Oh, that seemed to work.
So now y'all are my babies. Okay.
When I tell you life reps, and then when it goes viral on Instagram,
the clip about me talking about how life I realize it's an ID. Yeah. All right.
And that's how we promote the life rips culture.
And even if you got bit in the face by a dog life, still reps, all right.
And all of a sudden, yeah. Now natch making bags off it,
but that's how you do it. You let the people gravitate towards you.
You don't shove a saying or some
MOUs in people's face. Okay. So Sabra hummus,
this got all these suits in a room and decided, well,
we need a catch phrase. How about we shorten hummus to mus?
And then we make it like, it's a verb.
How do you mus now instant
BRM. My BRM meter is at an all time high. Now,
for those of you that don't know a BRM is, is blood red mat. Okay. Thriving.
Why am I seeing red? Because the blood's up to Hegar all right.
So they made a commercial.
How do you must? And it's got,
now I'm a fan of some of these people and I've met some of these people and
they're nice people,
but they put everybody that's like viral or in a meme
or famous for something either 50 years ago
or 20 years ago, or for something that lasted three days,
eight months ago in this commercial. And it is just so
what it is that I want to all over the place and leave it there for,
for 35 minutes. And guess what? Sabra? That's how I must.
Okay. How do you must? Oh, well what I do,
my pants and leave it there for 35 minutes and don't clean it up.
What are you doing, Chris? It smells. I'm mushing.
All right. So dude, this is the commercial and this is,
I don't even know who some of these people are. Some of these, I like America.
Okay. That's that guy? That wrestler guy. What's his name? Rick flair. Cool.
Rick flair. Great. You're back in the culture because the what's his,
what's the, uh, uh, the three Migos.
I'm going to call them the three Migos from now on. Is that why? They're the,
is that what it's supposed to be? Amigo?
Yeah. Migos, man. Get some Mexican hats or whatever they are.
Ah,
the three Migos.
You are the three Migos.
You're the three Migos. Did
I figured this stuff out. So anyway,
[inaudible] this guy's back like his count track. Could you be more?
This is how could he be more tracking?
You must count Dracula. All good count. Dracula or Monaco.
Oh dude, you MAs. Oh,
I just DDT someone wrestlers.
You know, now there's this chick who, I don't know who it is,
but she's laying like,
she's Nicki Minaj and she's got everything's yellow and she's
hot.
Then two people that are maybe trans. I don't know.
Am I in trouble now? But they're muscle.
Cause you got to get everybody Mohsen dude.
If they only had white people Musson or God forbid white,
straight white males Musson then their whole thing would be like, well wow,
Sabra you're canceled because of Musson. Everyone must is for everyone. Dude.
I guarantee that's. That would be, that would truly be what happened.
They'd be like, muscling is for everyone. This is. And I'd be in my pants,
leaving it there. And I, even though I'd be the straight white male,
I'll be like, this is how I'm Muslim. And I'm a straight white male.
That's T-Pain obviously no, of course. Of course.
That's sad. Okay. Of course. That's sad.
Okay. Why? Cause you know, T-Pain went bankrupt and if you don't know,
you still think about it for a little bit and you think, well,
of course he did though. So I do secretly know, even though I'd never read that.
And that's also the truth because he bought houses and all these cars.
Okay. Then now I like all these guys.
I like T pain's music. I liked the next one. Um,
uh, the guy who plays Steve Urkel. Jaleel white. Yeah. I like this guy.
Okay. But of course she's in this.
Okay.
Now Amanda, Sharon, it's 70, right? Yes. I know that.
Like her too. I love her business sense. She kills it.
It's inspiring. But because she's in this,
then there's a guy that, that looks like Tim Robbins. That's not Tim Robbins.
Don't know who this guy is, but he's mushing a pretzel pretzels.
Okay. Boomer. Oh,
an explosion
and explosion
and the explosion.
These suits in this thing.
A bunch of dudes. Just what about, uh, what about, okay, boomer? We got add that
explosion dude are me, man.
You're going to give a phrase.
That's got eight days keeping the internet on fire
three months ago.
And now it's in this commercial with this chick.
Who is.
This? I don't even know.
And then she puts a whole carrot in there with the leaf on it on the end, like,
God go yourself. What is she? A sociopath?
She's got the whole carrot in there with the leaf on the end.
Let these bugs bunny dude. And then she says, okay, boomer.
And then body rolls.
And exposion dude,
BRM meter is an all time high man. Are you kidding me, dude?
I want to take everybody from South Sabra hummus dude.
And I want to just take them out to dinner in a beautiful,
and I want the dinner to last. I don't want him to sleep over.
I don't want there to be any sex involved. I want to be hanging out.
I want to wake up and I want to go to breakfast with him.
I don't want to be having a great time and then do it.
I want to go get mimosas with them.
And then I want to have a little siesta and have some lunch and then I want to
take some muscle out and I want to put a spread out with all of the things,
the pretzels, the carrots, and all the.
And then I want to take them back to my veranda at
4:30 PM. And bro.
[Inaudible].
And be like, that's how I must, um.
Come on, dude. Okay. Boomer.
No dude.
Everyone on the thing under it. Okay. Boomer. Okay. Boomer. Okay. Boom robe.
Oh dude. That's Hey, you know what, dude?
Not funny. Also.
It's been around.
Boomer is a thing that has been around for long.
And now just because we're all going to say, okay. Boomer note, by the way,
the commercial is
15% through.
Now.
Yeah. To make it appeal to the, to other to everyone else besides whites.
So you've got this girl that just is pouring stuff. Hot sauce in it,
which is SRA cyst. Okay. She's got the Brown lady with the, with the,
with the hot sauce. Oh the okay. Boomer guys.
The boomer Esiason Oh, Oh, so it's clever. Okay. Oh, so it's clever. Oh.
And we can get boomers sizing and they say, well, how do you know?
We can get boomers sizing because he's not doing anything now.
Oh man.
And the Superbowl com okay. So then by the way,
I know you're watching this people at Sabra because there's pockets too big.
Every time I mentioned something, I get tweets.
They're going to send me a package of Sabra hummus,
and I'm going to have to roll around.
There's a, I must.
Pizza and subtitles just,
and then there's this kid who definitely is on tech talk.
I don't know who this kid and all the yellow is, but he's definitely on Tik TOK.
He's gaming.
Bananas. Don't don't lie. Nanas,
bananas, my spot and the Asian with the crab.
Bro, what, what, why is this so racist?
And then you got the Chester Cheetos guy.
Then this magician guy, which is like, it takes, it's like he's doing his magic,
but really it doesn't count if it's a commercial.
Cause you're just using special effects. He's not doing it.
They did it with Sabra, the cyber people back pain, the beef Turkey,
which is SRA cyst.
[Inaudible] this is how we
woo.
This is how we.
Dracula dude.
[Inaudible].
God idea was that whose
idea was it to have T Payne sing jerky at the end of the song?
Also, how much is that song? A garage band beat. They didn't even pay for it.
Cause they spent every, everybody they spent. So
they spent that they're like, we don't have any budget left for,
uh, a song and they'd be like, well, um,
garage band was popular in 1999.
Celery. I must pretzels. Okay. Boomer.
I see.
That girl is actually kind of cute how she does that. I can't hate, but also no.
Oh God dude. I want to be in that commercial for real.
And I want them to cut to me and be like,
I don't MOUs or me just with pants on and
leaking out of the ankles and
with a bunch of Sabra hummus all around and my feet are in it and I just go like
this and I go like this, this, this is how I must, I don't.
And then it cuts. But to boom, boom,
boom and boomer size and dipping a football in it.
This is how I might just get more and more crazy. And then me okay. Boomer.
This how I must [inaudible]
bro. If I see Sabra hummus around him, put my balls in it.